on vient chez nous à montréal le
déversement de 8 milliards de litres
d'eaux usées est toujours prévue à la mi
octobre dans une dizaine de jours
mais françois encore me voilà que le
gouvernement fédéral se dit inquiet et
environnement canada n'a toujours pas
donné le feu vert
effectivement patrice environnement
canada qui nous a envoyé un courriel en
fin de journée et persiste avec ses
affirmations en dix ans et je cite
environnement canada ne peut pas
autoriser ce type de rejet d'eaux usées
la loi interdit les rejets de substances
nocives dans les eaux où vivent des
poissons et aujourd'hui le gouvernement
fédéral avec le ministre denis lebel en
a ajouté une couche en disant qu'il
était préoccupé
cela dit denis coderre a tenu un point
de presse en appelant le gouvernement
fédéral à ne pas faire de politique avec
cet enjeu et en disant en nous apprenant
fait une nouveauté aujourd'hui qu'il y
avait déjà eu des travaux de même type
avec des déversements équivalent au
cours des dernières années en 2003 et en
2007 sur la même conduite alors
l'argument de denis coderre vous
l'entendrez c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on
l'accepté en 2003 et en 2007 et pas en
on écoute donc le ministre conservateur
denis lebel suivis du maire de morieux
la préoccupation est l'homme et comme
ancien marche prenais mes
responsabilités d'autres comme monsieur
coderre va faire demain mais on peut pas
aller de là on peut pas dire qu'on
protège notre environnement une
développer un plan sur le saint laurent
sans qu'on en assure la protection mais
je laisserai à la ville de montréal le
soin de prendre ses décisions mais il
était important pour nous de faire
savoir qu'on était interpellé par le
dossier j'espère que monsieur lebel fera
pas de la politique avec ça parce qu'en
2003 en 2007 il y avait eu aussi une
approbation d'environnement canada 6
blocks aux sottises et qui va bloquer
toutes les municipalités qui demande
environnement canada de faire un travail
parce que ça se rapproche de son niveau
de montréal reste à voir françois 2003
2005 est ce que c'était un déversement
d'eaux d'égout si importante d'abord un
et puis pour qu'on avait dit oui prend
dit non et chez environnement canada
vient pas eu plus de chance que nous on
ne parle pas notre jour pas notre vue il
ya plein de doutes qui persistent et ce
qui aura vraiment des conséquences
environnementales
les spécialistes qui on parle patrie
sont assez claires pour ce qui est de
l'eau potable
il n'y aura pas de conséquences puisque
l'eau est filtrée à l'entrée dans les
prises d'eau donc pour ça faut pas
s'inquiéter
maintenant évidemment en mettant les
égouts dans le saint-laurent tout ce que
vous pouvez jeter dans les toilettes
bon les excréments mais aussi par
exemple les préservatifs les tampons un
risque de causer de la pollution on nous
assure qui aura peu ou pas de
conséquences pour la faune et la flore
évidemment il ya un débat d'experts là
dessus et puisqu'on est en campagne
électorale fédérale
il ya également les politiciens qui s'en
mêle alors faudra voir au cours au cours
des prochaines des prochaines semaines
pendant que vous parliez françois ya
quelqu'un qui pêchait sur nos images pas
une très bonne idée
danny green le disait la semaine
dernière de pêcher pendant ces journées
là non effectivement la pêche la pêche
le surf toutes les activités avec
lesquels vous pourriez entrer en contact
avec l'eau seront d'ailleurs interdite
pendant cette période là merci françois
baroin